let's start with what will be the story
of the nfl until we know where he's
going to sign whether it's back with the
patriots or with a new team tom brady we
talked about potential replacements and
we focused on veterans what about the
possibility i'm not saying probability
likelihood or should but the possibility
of the new england patriots drafting a
quarterback may be in round one even to
try to come in and be their next guy do
you think they may do it and if so who
do you think that they would or should
pursue chris well i you know i again
i i guess i would look at one i don't
expect them to make that type of move i
don't you know one i i just think that
they do have confidence in jared sidham
for the future to be that guy uh and i
think they're very happy with that pick
would i be shocked if they took a
quarterback somewhere in the draft no
not necessarily but the first round
especially at pick 23. you know as it
looks right now and like i told you i
haven't got into like the the film study
of these college kids yet but i i don't
know if there's going to be anybody
there that's
close in the range of 23. they're in
kind of no man's land there as far as
getting that kind of guy now listen if
justin herbert fell and some maybe was
on the board at 17 or 18
maybe they do make a move for that kind
of guy i would think that would be the
type of guy they would want in this you
know maybe a tua but i have a hard time
believing tua gets out of the top you
know six or seven picks you know i i
could see it more likely of a justin
herbert maybe falling because of the
things we talked about a little bit
because that offense stinks and people
without getting scared that he's never
been out of eugene and all of that uh
but but you know for a team mike the
patriots they don't have a second round
pick
and it's gonna be hard for them to
i just don't imagine them trading up
into the top ten i guess to go
quarterback the draft you know road i
don't see that happening
yeah i don't disagree with you i i look
if somebody falls it's a different issue
altogether and as you said if somebody
starts sliding into the lower reaches of
round one i mean 23 you say they got the
23rd pick it's like my god when's the
last time they picked that high well it
would have been 2009. it's the last time
they got bounced before the divisional
round so they're not starting in as low
of a spot as they would have been
remember in 2015 they didn't have a
first round pick at all because of
deflategate so uh i i'm fascinated by
the possibility and i think bill
belichick is going to look at every
potential available candidate whether it
is a first wave of free agency
quarterback a second wave guy a guy who
gets supplanted by various moves a guy
who gets traded for weeks after free
agency begins but you know whatever it
takes to make the team better and really
what do they think about jared stidham
are they ready to hand the reins to him
they were ready to give the reins to tom
brady when drew bledsoe got injured in
september of 2001 and brady as a
sixth-round pick was in his second
season so you know we may be looking at
the state of now saying who knows a year
from now we'd be saying we may be saying
man jared stidham a pro bowler a guy who
took the team to the super bowl whatever
the case may be but um i think i think
that i'd be fascinated by tua if i was
the patriots right but i agree with you
they're not even close enough to even
get a whiff of two no i you know i just
have a hard time thinking tua gets out
of the top seven you know injury concern
or not i just think there'll be some
team there that's just gonna go okay
whatever we're gonna let them sit on the
bench you know and
also i don't know if tua really fits
what new england wants at quarterback
maybe they've changed but hey i mean tua
you know you can say what you want i
love watching him play he's got some big
time skill i get it still was scary i
mean that's he's scary as hell to me he
really is i would really be doing my
dude
due diligence
not a big guy you and i met him in the
super bowl we got to look at him that
way i mean he's not even in the same
stratosphere as like you know justin
herbert or joe burrow as far as size at
the quarterback and he plays a style of
football that can lend itself to getting
hit a little bit like we've seen and now
being a big guy that style of football
and an injury history that would just
absolutely scare me to death about tua
as much as i love watching them play and
i think there's going to be some teams
that look at that and have that same
feeling
you know this yeah i don't just i don't
disagree with that at all and uh does
just like new england let me ask you
this mike you think new england like
you know okay no andy dalton no ryan
tannehill who do you think is most
likely the next guy
they would look at that's like they're
on the market right now is like you know
a realistic option i mean where where do
you think that goes i think it might be
like case keenum
and then they bring case keenum in just
to compete with jared set up and go
there
i'm a believer in case keenum i know i
thought case keenum was spectacular in
minnesota in 2017. i thought the vikings
should have kept case keenum for 17
million instead of signing anyone at 28
million uh i he he's a guy especially if
you've got offensive line issues and the
patriots had offensive line issues he's
a guy who isn't mobile per se but
remember in 2017 chris it was the first
year we were doing this together he gets
flushed out of the pocket he goes
lateral he stops resets looks around he
can sense the walls closing in keeps
running resets and eventually somebody's
wide open i i love that in him and the
vikings figured out how to get the most
out of that and that would be a breath
of fresh air for a patriots offense that
is relied on tom brady stepping up in
the pocket and sliding left and right
without really running right they could
really do a lot of things and it would
cover up for a bad offensive line yes it
would i mean yeah i i hear you all there
and i'm with you i mean i think case
keenum is better than what people want
to give him credit for he was phenomenal
in that year in minnesota like you
talked about you know did some good
things with the redskins i mean let's be
serious the redskins aren't weren't that
talented didn't have that much help
around them either so nothing was going
to look that pretty but yeah very
fascinating the thing i also find
fascinating is like we don't even talk
about marcus mariota in this
conversation guys like that like where
the hell where the hell is that's a guy
whose name has been coming up in
connection with the patriots yeah i know
that shock you would that shock you if
you know you put marcus mariota in the
right spot
and uh you know where the coach is the
strong personality and you don't need
the quarterback to be as vocal of a
leader as maybe you need him to be in
other cities because that was the one
big knock right and i've met mariota a
couple of times it's like it's not a
whole lot of
dynamic personality radiating out of him
very nice guy very great athlete but i
don't know what kind of a quarterback he
is when you look at the full package
that's a fascinating possibility if the
patriots think that that they could get
more out of mariota than the titans yeah
it is you know i mean there's a lot of
things to like about mariota's game the
thing that's just going to scare the
patriots or any team that starts to
evaluate him is you know kind of what
you talked about a little there is just
the throwing itself the consistency
there can he be fixed can it be better
because that's my big concern i know you
and i have talked about this a lot over
the last few years it's just a lot of
like what i would say nfl
like this should be a consistent
completion type throw and pass and
receive you know reception and it just
doesn't happen a lot all the time with
marcus mariota his throwing can be
erratic and all over the place at times
and that's what ultimately led him to
get in bench this year
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports